what's up guys it's jerry and i am here
once again to talk to you about a film
that's right home slices hot skillets
Skrillex pan thing alright so this past
weekend I was treated to a screening of
a new film a new horror film because
that's right ladies and gentlemen
halloween is coming we're reaching the
end of the summer we are gearing down
from the heat you know the slip and
slides and the water parks and we're
getting ready for haunts and we're
getting ready for spooky decorations and
whatnot you know they release horror
movies all year long but I think we're
getting into the point in time now where
people are actually starting to think
about Halloween's coming you know so
I'll stop beating around the bush now we
saw as above so below that's right the
new found-footage horror movie that
takes place in the catacombs beneath
paris and this movie is interesting um
it's written and directed by the doubter
brother's a john erick dowdle and drew
down will i believe their name is and
you might know their name from such
films as the Poughkeepsie tapes and
quarantine and a film that I quite liked
called devil that a lot of people [ __ ]
on because of M night Shyamalan having
produced it most people don't realize
that he'd produced it and didn't write
and direct it it was written by the hard
candy guy that movie I really liked and
you know it's ever plays out like like a
long Twilight Zone episode and I've
heard it said that these guys improve
with every film so how does this theory
hold up now that they've got you know
another one um and
I don't know how that theory holds up
because as above so below is really
uneven experience in one like very
specific way that's what I'm so below
centers around I guess you would call
them archaeologists led by this girl
called Scarlett who's you know really
she's really pretty and very charming
and whatnot but she's also kind of a
sociopath um and she's always getting
into places she ain't supposed to be
looking for the fabled Philosopher's
Stone that Nicholas Flamel supposedly
created many many years ago which for
the first part of this movie when
they're talking about that so much
you're gonna be thinking a Harry Potter
if you know Harry Potter at all because
they're running around various parts of
Europe being like Oh Nicholas Flamel the
Sorcerer's Stone the Philosopher's Stone
we have to find it so I'm that's a thing
but um you've got her and then she sort
of assembles her her team or whatever
she gets a cameraman she goes to get her
friend played by I think his name is Ben
Feldman the actor um to to come along
with her and she thinks you know that
she's getting closer to figuring out
what the Sorcerer's Stone is and she
wants to find it and so that's sort of
the mission they're embarking on and the
thing about this movie is this the scary
parts the parts that matter I guess you
would say the most are good like are
actually well-constructed they're
actually very stressful they're actually
kind of jarring there's a scene in which
you know they're crawling through this
shoot in a cave and it's collapsing and
it's it's it's really sort of a lesson
in simplicity because it's just one shot
but is really stressful and effective it
was really cringe-worthy you know and
the other parts of this movie the
exposition stuff and then and the stuff
we're getting know the characters is
really weird and stiff um because the
thing about found footage movies in
general is that you know the conceit is
we're supposed to believe these are real
people going through a real situation
and that's part of what makes them so
scary
aside from the restrictive first person
point of view and that for the first 25
minutes you know the first act of this
movie it really doesn't solve any of the
problems that that keep you from sinking
yourself into a found-footage movie i
mean the the dialogue is really really
basic really expositional stuff to the
point where you know bad things are
happening and supporting characters will
be like this is bad for you like
literally and that kind of takes away
from your ability to immerse yourself in
this um and the film also threw out a
lot of it doesn't take any particular
strides to solve the whole like why are
you filming syndrome that so many
found-footage movie suffer from a lot of
times when they're filming uh where you
gotta wonder like why would the
cameraman be sitting across the room but
still filming this or you know why would
somebody pick up a camera and point into
their face in a very stressful situation
um you can just feel the movie you know
you never get lost and the movie never
allows you to forget that it's a movie
or at least it didn't really for me
until those stressful moments come out
um and you know you'll have these
characters to where they'll say that
like like like the Ben Feldman character
the whole time is like oh no I'm not
coming with you I'm not going in there
you know you could go you're crazy so
you got me locked up in a Turkish prison
for for a week you know I'm not doing
anything with you but he doesn't haven't
ever actually physically protest like
there's a whole scene where they're
going to the catacombs and he's like I'm
not going down there as he's walking
down there and then again he's like I'm
not going down there as he's getting
further down there and then he's like
standing next to this hole inside of a
cave and he's like I'm not going down
there and then something bad happens and
he immediately jumps the cave so
you can just feel there's a real
disparity between the script and the
film itself because the script sort of
instructs characters it has characters
say things because they have to because
I guess that's what sensible people
would say but the actions are the
opposite like like it feels like they
feel the need to placate us by going
like oh yeah he's totally reluctant even
though the action never supports that
idea so there's this really weird thing
where the script never allows you to
forget that it's there because it's so
sort of thin and basic but um you know
like I said when they get down into the
cave and [ __ ] starts to hit the fan that
stuff's genuinely spooky you know that
stuff's genuinely stressful and scary
there's some creative stuff going on
there's a lot of really jarring imagery
and things down there they don't
necessarily explain a lot of stuff but
there are things in that part of the
movie where you're like ooh like that's
just jarring to look at or or you know
nothing should you know be that way or
sound like that some of the things they
see in this little journey into their
own personal hell and those are
genuinely spooky so the stuff they find
in the catacombs and those situations
that's when the movies at its best
that's when the actors are at their best
that's what everything is that it's
because it's like these guys these these
two directors they seem competent they
seem like they're able to construct a
good scare the trouble is they need to
work on their writing because again a
lot of this stuff especially the
beginning feels like a first draft and
and it doesn't play out in a way that
feels realistic and characters don't
talk realistically enough when it counts
to make us believe the found-footage
elements so much this called attention
to itself so much inadvertently of
course but still it was just like oh I
don't believe any of this really I don't
know why anybody would go along with
this craziness but um you know for a fun
time on a friday night you know you want
to get together with your buddies you
want to have a couple scares it's
effective for that I mean the catacombs
they do
lend themselves this they certainly look
creepy and I seem like a good setting
for a horror movie so whoever had the
idea of setting a horror movie there you
know was clearly on the right track and
the way they play with sounds in this
movie especially you know in the in the
creepier kids is actually pretty cool
and jarring so I'm gonna get them credit
for that as well I also really like they
got some French actors for this you know
just to and I sort of like the way these
guys tend to end these movies at least
for this one in the last one um you know
they sort of end up just slightly in a
place you wouldn't have expected for
this kind of movies that's cool this
movie does leave a lot to be desired it
could have been a lot better put the
scary parts of scary and and creative so
I guess that's what matters so it's an
alright movie for that sort of stuff and
I did leave satisfied and you know I
always hate saying this but you know
it's like the rest of the movie when
it's not being scary I think you'll at
least be entertained because it's kind
of goofy um so yeah I'm okay on this
movie I mean these guys they may be
improving I feel like they need to take
some riding lessons because they did I
thought they did a really good job when
they had somebody else's script which
they did for devil with the heart the
guy were a hard candy wrote devil and
that movie i think is a lot better than
this one but this one isn't without its
charms so um yeah what's uh what are you
looking forward to this holiday season
now that that Halloween is on its way
are there any horror movies that you are
particularly excited for let's talk
about that anyhow until next time as
above so below is the movie I am Jerry